I have to put on my smart glasses
because it's time for the final thought
[Music]
president Trump's drawing of moral
equivalence between neo-nazis and antiva
thugs seemed tone-deaf at the time
because it miscalculated the enormity of
the offences and teeth amazed people
hurled rocks at them beat protesters
sure but a neo-nazi killed a woman with
his car of course both sides are odious
yet while Republicans and conservatives
at all levels from the grassroots to the
White House swiftly condemned the
criminals and kook's on their side
Democrats have kept a virtually mum on
antifa
because while neo Nazism and white
nationalism remain a fringe element on
the right a vanishingly small
alternative to everybody else leftist
violence to suppress speech is
widespread and even encouraged by
cheerleaders not on some fringe out left
but right square in the mainstream I'm
Michel Knowles this is the Michael Doyle
show come back tomorrow we'll do it all
again
[Music]
you
[Music]